you've got a great idea for the next big
app and you're just itching to get
started you want to develop in platform
that's easy to use and you want to make
sure it's going to scale up with you
after you make it big you want to pick
the language you're most comfortable
with and of course you don't want to
think too much about monitoring and
operations well it's time to check out
Google App Engine App Engine is a
managed application platform that
supports any language framework or
library you want to use we worry about
the infrastructure so you can focus on
your code you can get started today with
nodejs
Ruby PHP Go Java Python or even dotnet
and if that's not enough you can bring
your own custom container using any
programming language or library when
you're ready to deploy to the cloud just
run g-cloud app deploy App Engine will
take care of uploading your code and
running it on Google's infrastructure
for Java or.net lovers out there we have
great integration with Eclipse IntelliJ
and Visual Studio making it simple to
get started when you're ready to push
updates to your application App Engine
makes it easy you can run multiple
versions of your application at the same
time and can even split traffic between
different versions of your apps making
it simple to perform rollouts or a/b
testing as your application starts to
grow will automatically scale it for you
App Engine automatically balances
instances of your application across
multiple availability zones making sure
your app is up and available and if your
traffic flows down they'll automatically
scale the number of instances back down
as well of course no one writes perfect
code being able to debug and mantra
applications even in production is just
as important as deploying code App
Engine integrates seamlessly with Google
stack driver diagnostics monitoring
logging debugging tracing it's all
available out of the box with minimal
setup and configuration running your
code in the cloud is just the start you
need databases caches scalable file
storage and here's where the rest of
Google cloud platform comes in App
Engine lets you leverage you powerful
systems without needing to worry about
setup or infrastructure our goal with
App Engine is to make developing
applications for cloud just a little bit
easier you bring the code and
handle the rest I can't wait to see what
you'll build next